[Music]
[Music]
the tale that i'm about to tell you
might be the strangest thing you're
going to hear today in the rocky heart
of central asia nearly a century ago an
english pickle manufacturer briefly
became the king of a breakaway nation
he was born bertram shell drake but was
later known as the pickle king of
tartary
this is the story of how it all happened
[Music]
bertram sheldrake was born in london in
1888 the same year that rudyard kipling
published the man who would be king a
fictional story of how two british
adventurers became the kings of
kefiristan a remote region in northern
afghanistan their good fortune turns
however as the pair are slowly corrupted
by their newfound power following a riot
they are violently overthrown by their
afghan subjects as we shall see
sometimes reality is stranger than
fiction
bertram's father gosling had made his
living as a manufacturer and distributor
of pickles
you know cucumbers left to ferment in
vinegar due to the british public's lack
of taste buds it was a successful
operation
soon g-shell drake's pickles branched
out into ketchup chutney sauces capers
vinegar and curries basically anything
to go with fish and chips on the back of
his father's pickle money bertram was
able to attend a private boarding school
it was during this time that he was
introduced to the philosophy and
teachings of islam and its principles of
peaceful service to god and humankind
this chance introduction would become
pivotal for young bertram for at a young
age of 15 he renounced his catholic
faith and converted renaming himself
khalid a central practice in islam is
helping those who are less fortunate a
principal known as zakat having now
inherited his father's pickle business
khalid cheltrick donated much of his
earnings to charity he also helped fund
one of britain's first purpose-built
mosques which opened in monsworth south
london
sheldrick's philanthropy had earned him
a reputation but british newspapers
could not understand why this well-to-do
gentleman had adopted islam
tabloid articles and magazines were
known to mock
in response sheldrake wrote a letter to
king george v about the abuse that many
british muslims undergo in this letter
he called for the end of the many quote
cartoons in which the muslim faith and
its prophet were made fun of but
sheldrake's reputation would go truly
international when he assisted in the
conversion of gladys palmer the daughter
of a wealthy biscuit magnate by the way
what's with this story and snacks
he performed the ceremony aboard a
chartered airliner flight above the
english channel reciting the shahada
over the din of the plane's engines
newspapers went into a frenzy over this
and not just in the uk the story was
covered in magazines across europe
america and the middle east
news reached the furthest of places
including an often forgotten region in
central asia a place known to many
english speakers at the time as tartary
roughly 3600 miles from london in the
far western corner of china is an arid
and rocky province known as xinjiang
because of its harsh climate very few
people live here but those that do are
known as the uyghurs a turkic people
followers of islam with their own unique
language and culture at the center of
this region is the historic capital
kashgar for centuries it was the
northern hub of the silk roads a vast
intersecting network of trade routes
that ran from beijing to byzantium as
travellers passed through the city camel
caravan in tow they exchanged exotic
goods from foreign lands as a sheer
coincidence to our story one of these
goods included pickles with cucumbers
traded from india early chinese builders
were some of the first to preserve the
mint vinegar during the construction of
the great wall these pickled cucumbers
could be placed in jars and so were
readily portable the perfect snack for a
silk road trip it was via this ancient
trade network that pickles first arrived
in france somewhere between the 8th and
9th centuries ever since they've become
staples in several european cuisines
anyway because of kashgar's lucrative
position along the silk road this region
has passed through the hands of its
larger neighbours in the 13th century it
was a vassal state to the mongol hordes
under chingas khan and by the 18th
century it was ruled by the chinese qing
dynasty who made it its westernmost
province fast forward to 1933 and there
was an immense period of upheaval in
china a civil war between the
nationalists and the communists it was
amid this fragmenting state that the
people of xinjiang saw an opportunity to
break away
with the city of kashgar as its capital
uyga nationals swiftly declared the
turkic islamic republic of east
turkestan but recorded the etr for short
the fledgling state wanted recognition
on the world stage and one way to do
this is with a popular figurehead the
story goes that various uyghur groups
could not decide on a leader amongst
their own people and so they agreed that
the leader had to be from the outside it
just so happened that at this time news
about a prominent convert from england
had reached kashgar they had found a
suitable leader and a delegation was
sent to london
as a quick side note it's unknown
whether any of this was actually known
to the etr's president a man called kojo
niaz most of what remains about this
story are from western newspapers from
the time and so they may contain some
fanciful elements either way we do know
that when the delegation arrived to
south london home calachel drake eagerly
accepted their invitation he renounced
his former life as a pickle manufacturer
and accepted the title of his majesty
king khalid of islamistan shortly
thereafter sheldrake joined his future
subjects as they boarded a ferry to hong
kong hearing news of this remarkable
story british tabloids came up with all
sorts of names from the english mere of
kashgar to lord of the rooftop of the
world but there's one that really stuck
the pickle king of tartary
having arrived in beijing by the spring
of 1934 the soon to be king khalid
prepared to make the roughly 2 000 mile
land journey to kashgar along the
ancient paths that once made up the silk
road however the moment the chinese
nationalist government heard of their
rogue province's plans to install a
pickle king they were suspicious what
was a british man who had never been to
xinjiang doing accepting the title of
king the soviets to the northern border
accused sheldrake of being an agent of
the crown making xinjiang just another
colony of the british empire i mean are
we to blame them for thinking this at
the time britain was still intoxicated
with its ill-gotten empire with an
estimated quarter of the world's
population under its dominion
even the etr's pals weren't too pleased
about the prospect of a pickle king the
neighbouring kingdom of afghanistan who
had once helped this breakaway republic
break away withdrew their political
support as he was on route to kashgar
khalid sheldrake was totally unaware of
this he had no communication with the
outside world when he finally arrived in
august it was clear that the etr was
already in a right royal pickle and not
the one they'd been expecting a joint
effort between the chinese nationalists
and the soviets had quashed the uyghur
rebellion and reclaimed xinjiang with
the dream of his kingdom collapsing
before his eyes and fearing his own
safety sheldrake fled and made his way
to british occupied india
soon khalid sheltrak returned to england
where he lived as a king in exile he
resumed his philanthropy work and
continued to raise funds for muslim
charities and build new mosques in his
spare time he was known to give lectures
on the current state of xinjiang as well
as the uyghur people for many however it
was just simply too far away to be of
interest they were more preoccupied with
the news surrounding an austrian art
school reject and his national socialist
party in germany
after the second world war ended
sheldrick lived out his days in his
south london home dying in 1947 at the
relatively young age of 59.
after his death this bizarre story faded
into obscurity like a cucumber in brine
this apocryphal tale from central asia
is preserved in only a few surviving
articles sheldrick's moniker the pickle
king of tartary has an amusing ring to
it and when i first heard the story i
thought i'd be making a light-hearted
video but i think this story is more
complicated than that and i suspect
depending on your own life experiences
you'll react to it in a number of ways
you might see khalid sheldrake as the
charitable philanthropist a patron of
britain's muslim communities and someone
who called out bigotry to the highest
authorities in the land but you might
also see it as a story of empires and
colonies and a naive man at the center
of it like rudyard kipling's cautionary
tale who himself was a staunch
imperialist by the way you may ask
whether it's ever right to rule the
place if you've never even been since
the chinese civil war ended in 1949
xinjiang has been a province in the
people's republic of china however in
recent years there have been some
allegations coming out of xinjiang about
the various human rights abuses against
the uyghur people although something
that the chinese communist party has
vehemently denied as it stands the
situation is very much ongoing and if
you want to learn more about this i
provided links in the description below
the pickle king of tartary is a strange
footnote in the often turbulent history
of central asia to my mind the story
about how a pickle manufacturer nearly
became a king is certainly one of those
obscure topics that deserve more
attention
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you're new
here and want to see more why not
subscribe a like and a comment also go a
really long way anyway i look forward to
seeing you next time
goodbye